today is May 11 2015 and this is the
first video I'm making as a full-time
youtuber hey what's up guys I'm Kip EHD
here and coming off a bit of a quiet
week I was finishing up school literally
and this is a sort of a five facts about
me video sort of five more facts I did a
five facts about me a couple months or
years ago and a couple of those facts
are a little bit changed now but this
you could see as a sort of an update
video so fact number one the name mkbhd
when I first signed up for YouTube I
didn't sign up with mkbhd it was just my
name marques Brownlee one-word no-spaces
that's kind of hard to remember and also
kind of hard to search if you can't
spell right on the first try so I needed
a way to shorten the name in a way that
people could find it also when I first
started making like a lot of videos I
wanted to intro every new video in a way
that would remind people or let people
know that I had also made other videos
so I started off with this like big long
sentence like hey guys
marques Brownlee here back with another
high definition video or something like
that and that's the way it all started
hey what's up guys it's Marcus Brownlee
here from mkbhd and I got another
software video for you guys today you
guys were asking for software so here it
is
I eventually shortened and compacted and
crunched down and crunch down that
sentence over and over again
to make it basically what you know today
as what's up guys mkbhd here mkb being
my initials HD being high-definition and
just getting right into the video
fact number two is I don't really watch
that much TV at all now I've lived in
this apartment that you've seen around
me in these videos for three years now
and I have never in that time had a
cable subscription never been plugged
into TV the only things that my TV are
plugged into are a ps4 and Xbox one and
a chromecast and playing an Apple TV and
that's about it so about a month ago I
actually finally bought a TV
subscription for the first time while
living here just to watch the NBA
Playoffs
which have been amazing by the way if
you haven't already seen all the budget
leaders let's go Clippers back number
three is actually an amendment to one of
the
facts that was in the original five
facts about me video this is the
professional team that I played for the
New Jersey hammerheads so in the United
States in New Jersey there is a
professional team called the New Jersey
hammerheads that I play for and
professional Ultimate Frisbee player
yeah so I'm still a professional athlete
and it's still ultimate but the
hammerheads don't exist anymore so I'm
currently playing for an MOU team called
the New York Rumble and we have away
games all up and down the east coast of
the US and we have home games in Queens
in New York City so I'll go ahead and
leave this schedule ripe oh I like
button if you want to check it out and
maybe even come to a game fun fact
number four I hate the cold I hate it I
don't think I would do well in much
other places the world that are much
colder than here I've been trying to
shoot more video outdoors lately because
there's a lot of free light out there
but obviously the weather hasn't exactly
been cooperative the the last winter we
had on the East Coast here was brutal so
yeah it'll probably end up having of
some effect on where I end up living
after college but bottom line it's not
like I dislike New York City or anything
but there are places that are much nicer
whether same deal as an athlete even if
I'm not shooting videos outside I play
ultimate ever since I broke my hand it
takes longer in cold weather to warm up
my wrist again because the ligaments in
there it's just not a good time so I
would rather see like a place that's 70
degrees all the time that'll be great
fact number five is I'm done with
college well not I my graduations in
about two weeks but I finished the last
class of my senior year so as far as I'm
concerned I'm done so the simple fact is
I've been doing this YouTube thing
part-time for well since I've been doing
it I've been a full-time student my
whole life basically that's all you
really get to do in college so as a
result no matter how many hours I put
into video I always feel like I'm behind
on the videos I want to make and even if
you know I'm never first I already know
that but even the videos that aren't
time-sensitive take a lot of hours to
put together so the point is now that's
changed now I am technically a full-time
video maker is what I would say and
that's a huge opportunity you guys
already know this wouldn't be possible
without you guys I seriously appreciate
everyone who not only watches but
everyone who leaves comments and
feedback to make the videos
better everyone who supports everyone
who's following and watching basically
anything that I make and so now that I'm
making these videos as just what I do I
get to really dedicate myself to that my
full-time goal has always really been to
make videos that I would want to watch
and I'm excited to put a lot more hours
into doing exactly that so it's going to
be a good summer excited to get started
with this stuff thank you for watching
this one and the next one is right
around the corner of course because
that's what I get to do now thanks for
watching talk to you guys the next one
peace
and instead of 1,000 subscribers maybe I
want 1.3 million subscribers I don't
know